let's bring in Louisiana Senator John
Kennedy so Senator how has the Three
Amigos Summit been going
well I am I'm pleased that President
Biden went to the Border
I'm pleased that he says he will do
better
in terms of enforcing America's
immigration laws
um but the American people may be poorer
under President Biden but they're not
stupid
to be trusted you have to be trustworthy
and when it comes to the board of
President Biden has not been trustworthy
um when when it comes to the Border
President Biden is um
he's about as credible as uh as Jesse
smallett who at any moment could
announce that uh Will Smith slapped him
too so what I say to the president is if
you want to be trusted about the in
Border and force the law
finish the wall uh Institute a remaining
Mexico program
execute safe Third Country agreements uh
declare the Mexican cartels foreign
terrorist organizations
here's my worry though Jesse I worry
that all of this is a ruse I worry that
what the president really intends to do
is introduce a bill into Congress that
says I will enforce the law as soon as
you grant people who are in our country
illegally amnesty
and I worry especially that he will
convince enough Republicans to take to
take the bullet train to chumptown and
vote for the bill and it will become law
and that will make the human train wreck
at the border immeasurably worse
uh I think the American people won't
stand for it nor should they when you
when you poll whether uh illegal
immigration is appropriate uh the the
only people who support her 23 year old
gender studies make especially American
people say it's against the law duh
enforce them all duh enforce the law put
it on a bumper sticker Senator Kennedy
thanks as always
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else